we're travelers going miles through mud
and muck hey Jean Luc how's it going
pretty good iron alright so we got a
Ghost Recon wildlands trailer that
dropped today we're going to go over
some of the things that you may have
missed now four people are just getting
caught up Ghost Recon wildlands is a
supposedly open world co-op shooter from
Ubisoft it seems to be very much in the
vein of safe Far Cry meets ghost recon
future soldier and a lot of the
mechanics in the game especially from
this trailer seemed to show combined
arms so the first thing they show here
is a guy sniping yes I'm assuming that
he is covering his co-op buddies that
you kind of using the terrain to
advantage I can have a guy get up on
high and kind of like scope everything
out while my buddies are kind of like
getting in up close here we actually do
see buggies with chain guns mounted on
the top so I you know I think to a
certain extent at least you will be able
to go in with vehicles guns blazing and
then I think you'll have the players who
want to do the very quiet stealth runs
such as this scene here where they're
basically shown sneaking in and putting
c4 on a drug stash so here we see a
couple guys jumping out of the
helicopter with some parachutes again
very stealthy and something I'm curious
about is multiplayer wise how does this
work is that a player driving the
helicopters on MPC so here we see them
assaulting what looks like a much larger
outpost so again I'm wondering if this
is an instance or if this is in the open
world itself the scene here with the
drones pretty cool that drones straight
out of ghost recon future soldier it was
used in future soldier to mark targets
and then synchronize kills with a
countdown this scene is kind of
interesting because here we see a
stealth take down as players invade this
compound but then later on in the
footage we see them take down two guards
standing right in front of them so I
wonder if there is a stealth mechanic
versus a gain their trust and then
double-cross them mechanic in this game
they show a couple of shots in this
compound one I see a radio tower which
looks a lot like just cause and I'm
going to probably throw this out there
but you can probably drop it in the
following scene we actually see an alarm
tower from Far Cry em which is the very
Ruby soft thing to do here we got a
special operations
rib boat which are commonly used in
river and shore operations but i think
all all they're trying to show here is
that throughout this trailer you see
them flying in helicopters you see them
driving in boats you see them on
motorcycles and dune buggy is so i think
they're just trying to show you that you
will have a just caused level of freedom
to roam the map yeah so we're shown a
lot of vehicles sort of like driving
away chase sequences and i wonder if
that is there going to be an emphasis on
okay you blew up the you blow up the
drugs now you have to flee and sort of
like an escape sequence which could be a
lot of fun if you get chased and if you
go lad and then you you have to get away
and you're getting chased by the cartels
you know again a lot of the fun from
this game i think will come from doing
it with your friends and having that the
coop ability and something we haven't
mentioned yet is that they've shown a
really good variety of locations in this
trailer i don't know if it's one map or
if it's multiple maps like Metal Gear
Solid 5 or maybe you're going to
different locations we see a number of
guns in this trailer too so here you can
see an ACR assault rifle which is
basically an assault rifle that was
designed to swap out barrels and chamber
different rounds you could customize it
for the range which actually fits into
the ghost recon weapon customization
theme that a lot of these games have so
I'm assuming this is one of those guns
you can probably swap out in the field
this is clearly not stealth they're
actually facing these two guys and
talking to them so this seems like one
of those moments in the game where you
might be able to gain a gangs trust and
then double-cross them they have a scene
of them walking in a village with
civilians and I think that could
potentially be interesting because I
think a games like far cry that have
these open landscapes but every person
you encounter in those games is an enemy
and so the idea of oh no you actually
have these locations with NPCs and
civilians and you know making sure
they're not involved in a firefight
could potentially be interesting whether
you might have to get the locals trust
or win over the locals it's it's a
mechanic of guerrilla warfare it'd be
interesting to see if it's translated
into the into Ghost Recon wildlands
itself this is my favorite shot of this
entire trailer just because of the cobra
helicopter I'm really curious at this
stage if what this shot is implying is
that players can come in
on vehicles all four I think I'm
assuming it's four players can all come
in on vehicle so i can actually have
somebody flying a helicopter somebody
driving in a motorcycle and somebody in
a buggy because that would be really
interesting in this game turned into a
combined arm style game where you could
actually go out objectives with a
combination of vehicles and snipers and
you know people on the ground shooting
just in terms of gameplay that that's
very exciting to me that leaves me
worried about if I'm playing single
player how much of this cool stuff do I
actually get to do because it's like
well I'm by myself so I can't drive all
these vehicles at once you know like is
it still going to have like that cool
impact to it but then also presumably it
alive matchmaking is that something I'm
going to want to do if I have these
random people in my group like can we
effectively actually coordinate a
strategy or is it going to just sort of
be like mass chaos and like well we
technically did it but you know like the
guy just drove the helicopter into the
ground and and exploded and then like I
guess I started shooting and it kind of
worked out yeah I think at the end of
the day the question is how GTA is this
world or how like instanced in linear is
it because you can still have an open
world but then you just lock players
into certain areas and and limit what
they can do again like I think the big
question is how much freedom do you have
according to this trailer it seems like
a lot but again this is a this is an in
engine trailer which doesn't necessarily
mean these are the things that you can
do as players and we don't know which
one of these are actually cutscenes a
lot of these scenes in the trailer have
a very cinematic look which makes you
question am I actually is that a scene
where I'm actually escaping in a dune
buggy or is that like a cutscene you
just kind of don't know all right
closing thoughts John Luke I think the
visually I mean the trailer looks
amazing just like graphically I think it
looks great and I'm very excited to see
exactly what type of open world it is
you know Ubisoft they have a formula
with their open world and you know
they've been showing like the civilian
stuff emphasis on vehicles they have the
potential this to be more unique then
you know Far Cry could stand out but
can't really say until they actually
show more of the game which I assume
they will at e3 at the end of the day
when you put combined arms co-op
together in an open world I'm definitely
in I'm pretty excited for the potential
of this game and yeah we'll see 83 what
it is as a player that you can act
should we do alright thanks John Luke
yeah thanks we're ghosts and we do not
exist
you